may you raise your hands please great
[Music]
climate crisis we only have a few months
left I love that you support the Green
Deal but it's not get it you know get it
with a fossil fuel it's not gonna solve
the problem fast enough
a Swedish professor saying that we can
eat their dead people but that's not
fast enough so I think your next
campaign slogan has to be this we got to
start eating babies we don't have enough
time there's too much co2 all of you you
are you you know your pollutant too much
co2 we have to start now please you are
so great I'm so happy that you really
support a nuclear deal but it's not
enough you know even if we would barb
Russia we still have too many people too
much pollution so we have to get rid of
the babies that's a big problem just
stopping a baby's a silent lab we need
to eat the babies under this very soon
please
Ekans no thank you thank you we'll go
ahead okay
[Music]
no we'll go ahead it's a no-no you know
thank you
so I think um ya know so one of the
things that's very important to us is
that we need to treat the climate crisis
with the urgency that it does present
luckily we have more than a few months
we do need to hit Net Zero in several
years but I think we all need to to
understand that there are a lot of
solutions that we have and that we can
pursue and that if we act in a positive
way there is space for hope there's we
are never beyond hope
[Applause]